notre correspondante magdalena shadow
vnnic bonjour magdalena avec dallas je
le disais la pologne affirme avoir
accueilli cent mille ukrainien ces
derniers jours c'est bien ça est-ce que
l'afflux de réfugiés ukrainiens se
poursuit toujours ce samedi
oui bonjour à tout le monde je suis à
jamais pas loin de la frontière est la
frontière
de chemin de fer aussi avec relève au
cren c'est vrai que les gardes frontière
ont confirmé aujourd'hui que cent mille
de personnes ont déjà croisé la
frontière polonaise il ya beaucoup de
gens de l'autre côté deux côté ukrainien
qui le qui attend toujours
je parlais avec des gens de l'autre côté
il me disait que parfois ça prend s'il
part en voiture ça prend même 24 heures
en fait pour passer la frontière
le train qu'ils arrivent ici avec la de
l'ukraine ils sont cinq
parfois cette heure d'été les a mais il
arrive souvent il arrive toujours
aujourd'hui on attend quelques hommes
quelques trains ce que ce qu'on était
dit aussi plus vifs à lévis ils ont
décidé de rajouter trois trains en plus
pour le civil qui veulent aller en
pologne donc on fait sain
en flux de réfugiés ont cramé ici en
pologne magdalena un mot également avec
vous du dispositif qui a mis en place la
pologne ces dernières heures pour
accueillir les réfugiés ukrainien et ses
neuf centrales qui ont été mis en place
et ce que les autorités polonaises
il envisage d'étendre ce dispositif pour
le moment
pas on s'est un moment tout à fait on a
neuf points d'accueil mais il faut
savoir que le point d'accueil sont juste
le point de passage donc il ya beaucoup
plus de points d'accueil en pologne dans
le dans le pays ici on voit juste des
gens qui vient d'arriver pour se
détendre un tout petit peu pour se
renseigner pour affronter en formation
après ils sont dirigés encore plus en
peul il ya deux régions de 6 des
citoyens peu le nez qui vient ici pour
le chercher qui sont déjà ouvert pas mal
de portes de leur domicile pour
accueillir le secret niant mais aussi le
gouvernement envisage de de les
accueillir dans le centre officiel
préparé par le gouvernement donc tout le
monde qui est ici qu'on voit ici à
psaume riches sont des gens qui justin
passe ses points d'accueil pour en fait
aller plus loin soit en pologne soit
dans le pays européenne comme italie
allemagne quand ils ont à quoi ils ont
dit merci beaucoup magdalena show
devenick pour toutes ces précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes l'envoyé spécial
de france 24 dont près de la frontière
ukrainienne en pologne donc